salut à tous tous les jours une énigme
en tout cas tous les jours durant l'été
puisque on va s'arrêter à la fin du mois
pour reprendre le rythme normal
avant de vous donner l'énigme du jour je
vous donne la solution de l'énigme tests
psychologiques d'hier j'espère que vous
n'avez pas trouvé la réponse vous
expliquerai pourquoi si vous n'avez pas
vu la vidéo d'hier regardez là avant
d'écouter la réponse d'aujourd'hui et
bien elle a tué sa soeur parce qu'elle
espérait que le garçon comme ça
viendrait aux funérailles et cas
pourrait le revoir
il semblerait c'est ce qui se dit mais
moi j'ai trouvé aucune source confirmant
sa en tout cas sur le sujet que c'est un
test qu'on faisait pour détecter si
quelqu'un était psychopathe ou pas donc
c'est une très très bonne nouvelle si
vous n'avez pas trouvé la réponse
il faut être un petit peu tordu pour
trouver la réponse et si vous avez
trouvé la réponse
moi je vous le dis vous n'êtes pas tordu
vous êtes juste super intelligent mais
moi j'avais pas trouvé la réponse
du coup je suis content et si vous le
faites à des amis avoué qu'ils trouvent
la réponse conseille quand même d'autres
un peu prudent allez on passe à l'énigme
du jour
énigme 25 l'énigme d'un père et de son
fils un père et son fils on a eu 2 36
ans c'est à dire que si on additionne
lors 2h ça nous fait 36 sachant que le
père à 30 ans de plus que son fils
quel âge à l'office ça paraît simple
comme ça donc prenez le temps d'y
réfléchir un petit peu ne mettez pas la
réponse dans les commentaires si vous
avez trouvé m'étais juste j'ai trouvé
mettez un pouce en l'air pour qu'on voit
le nombre de personnes qui ont trouvé la
solution solution que je vous donnerai
comme d'habitude dans la prochaine vidéo
profiter encore du soleil des quelques
derniers jours de vacances du mois
d'août si vous êtes en vacances pensez
bien sûr à vous abonner avant de partir
et rendez vous demain à 17h ciao